w-t-f-l-o-l-l-m-f-a-l not the location  of the murders and it's worse than we  expected html an influencer lives don't  move this is the police i don't give a f  okay my social website gets like 1200  hits a day jesus i have an army of  followers and like 300 people on discord  you've brainwashed them i also have a  youtube channel where i can spread my  sick twisted message what's it called  man carrying things tell your people to  back down i can't at the snap of my  fingers i can make them do whatever i  tell them to do  it definitely they definitely will  listen to me what about the murders  that's wha what murders we've got the  wrong guy this is just some sick [ __ ]